♪ If I could feel the memory ♪
♪ Instead of turning back time ♪
♪ I know that the past is all ♪
♪ That's left of you and I ♪
♪ I'd relive when we first met ♪
♪ When you caught my eye ♪
♪ The rush of us and all that was ♪
♪ Right now would be so nice ♪
♪ But I know ♪
♪ When Christmas comes around ♪
♪ And the snow ♪
♪ Falls like a fresh start on the ground ♪
♪ You aren't the one I'm missing ♪
♪ He left long ago ♪
♪ But Christmas Eve, my gift to me ♪
♪ Is dancing with your ghost ♪
♪ So Merry Christmas ♪
♪ To the one I used to know ♪
(gentle piano music)
♪ Once a year I let my heart
go back to you and me ♪
♪ A secret gift I give myself ♪
♪ On Christmas Eve ♪
♪ If I could feel the memory ♪
♪ Instead of turning back time ♪
♪ I know that the past is all ♪
♪ That's left of you and I ♪
♪ Still I know ♪
♪ When Christmas comes around ♪
♪ And the snow ♪
♪ Falls like a fresh start on the ground ♪
♪ You aren't the one I'm missing ♪
♪ No, he left long ago ♪
♪ But Christmas Eve, my gift to me ♪
♪ Is dancing with your ghost ♪
♪ So Merry Christmas ♪
♪ To the one I used ♪
♪ To know ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)